aujourd'hui chers amis nous allons tout
savoir sur le pâté aux pommes de terre
vous allez voir vous prenez des pommes
de terre dans un pâté non pas n'importe
quel le pâté aux pommes de terre vous
seriez trop content moi aussi j'ai pour
parler de ce problème grave du pâté aux
pommes de terre la joie d'accueillir un
chef meilleur ouvrier de france gilles
johanet bonjour gilles bonjour françois
ça va bien rien originaire de l'allier
pour la du bourbonnais du bourbonnais
c'est la recette locale local de chez
nous alors j'y jouais à anna n'est pas
n'importe quel chef comme vous pouvez le
constater c'est un chef en blanc comme
tous les chefs blancs mais vous remarqué
et vous commencez à être habitués autour
du cou il a du bleu blanc rouge et ce
n'est pas des rubans qu'on achète dans
la porte dès lors une mercerie si vous
le voulez gagner courageusement oui la
bataille des fourneaux fut dur ac c'est
le titre de meilleur ouvrier de france
de cuisine en quelle année gilles 1979
ça nous rajeunit pas pas du tout alors
on se fait un petit pâté aux pommes de
terre c'est bon c'est facile et c'est
pas cher assez facile et c'est pas cher
quels sont les ingrédients en charge et
que tout d'abord un coup de patte un peu
de pas plus de tolérance la patrick
terre très bien ensuite des pommes de
terre ou des pommes de terre le sel du
poivre
l'indispensable de la poitrine demi sel
oui du cerfeuil surfer et la ciboulette
du persil les échalotes 1 jaune d'oeuf
pour faire de la dorure notre pape de la
crème du beurre ruines beurrer notre
mouvement et de la farine pour
travailler notre pari de la farine pour
farine et car sans farine on ne peut pas
farine et huile ça nous pose que des
problèmes ne gèlent blanchir donc alors
blanchir blanchissant cheryl petit quart
d'heure lessive émincés et je vais jeter
le détergent pour blanche et
uniquement de l'eau que l'on porte avec
le produit en ayant le génial au regard
des lacets le coup de couteau d'un élève
dans la cuisine du mof et ont dit oui
chef ou alors vous savez que le café de
la paix c'est une institution en fait ça
date de l'époque ce café de la paix bien
nous avons fait les 120 ans du café de
la paix
alors regardez blanchir j'ai mon brevet
je monte un peu la montée un peu les
feux et ont porté aux munitions quelques
minutes dans l'eau bouillante
ça se fait tout seul en détruit nous
allons passer on ne dit pas le nom de
l'instrument car si vous trouvez le
nombre d'instruments vous nous écrivez
et je m'arrangerais avec gilles johanna
pour qu'il vous offre une poignée de
main n'est ce pas jaloux on verra alors
vous vous avez reconnu le nom de cet
instrument
immortalisée par une chanson regardez on
peut faire même de la musique avec cet
appareil est un appareil très
perfectionné en plus comme le café de la
paix située juste en face du palais
garnier allait gagner le palais garnier
je ne vous demanderai pas de nous
envoyer une carte postale pour nous dire
que c'est l'opéra de paris que le
plafond de votre établissement a été
peint par le même garnier par lui-même
voilà c'était notre quart d'heure
monuments historiques qui n'est pas un
monument en péril heureusement cette
porte bien avec tout le monde juste pour
tous bien joué
attention les doigts
dans votre misère pousse ça peut servir
alors regardez cet instrument fabuleux
sert à
émincez les pommes de terre les légumes
de mary groupe emma c'est autre chose
donc vous avez
vous avez tous noté vous avez tout
compris vous nous écrivez et vous nous
donnez le nom de l'instrument
ne vous trompez pas vous ne le voyez pas
à mon confrère lyonnais levadia vous
l'envoyez à 100 mais bon y'a pas
meilleur 28 pour albert 1er
75 08 paris donc là à une vitesse grand
v grâce au tgv ces instruments voilà on
a un nom des pommes de terre salée sans
lamelles terres salées pas dessus
un peu de poivre du moulin alors vous
êtes je peux le bocuse
il est également meilleur ouvrier bonne
partisans du blanc du noir
du black or vous nous dites que vous
avez envie de dire si vous ne voulez
parler du monde si vous considérez que
c'est un secret ces vauriens de recevoir
ce ne peut être que très bien alors la
deuxième exercice nous allons émincer
l'échalote regarde les j'adore parce que
c'est de la jfpi vers lui on été
magnifique c'est du travail
amusez vous essayez donc de l'otan il
vous allez voir normalement il vaut
mieux le service des urgences soit
relativement près de votre domicile
qu'est ce que vous faites là vous
refiler les phalanges voudrait mieux oui
ça me rappelle un peu de rangement je
vais branger cet instrument mystérieux
ni
regarder
habituellement elle fait d'avancé puis
il existe dans l'électroménager des
appareils avec des moteurs électriques
oui merci ça va très bien pas de
publicité s'il vous plaît vous savez que
c'est formellement interdit sur les
chaînes publiques on va croire que je
suis l'inventeur de cet instrument
électrique
que je peux faire pour vous gilles et
vous pouvez me casser
un peu doux c'est normal je prends un
peu de
garder un oeil en direct sous les
caméras de jean-michel boussaguet voilà
c'est parfait je me débrouille pas trop
mal kick ass 1,9 peut aussi casser un
boss vous avez peut-être un autre russe
et bien voilà ça va servir un doré
j'ai pris les chiffres eux que je
mélange avec mon père c'est très bien
vous mélangez peut-être que tout va bien
pour maintenant nous sommes dans les
temps car cette recette se réalise en
grès alors approché un peu d'eux c'est
une rolls leur tête le hbh au point
grossièrement
à moins que lieberman et non pas du tout
c'est grossièrement gilles vous faites
de la cuisine depuis 120 ans personne ne
l'a remarqué
c'est ce que me disait encore votre ami
jérôme anger l'autre jour gilles on ne
voit pas passer les gens vous avez
commencé quand et vous avez après tout
j'ai commencé à l'âge de 15 ans
oui c'est un beau pays
étrangers ces mecs un peu partout lors
de mes collègues je vais couper oui les
lardons enfin l'eau qui faire à blanchir
le lardin parce que sinon dont l'âge est
mince
un petit peu de ciboulette une recette
toute simple pas franchement et mathé
alors après le bourbonnais vous êtes
monté à paris en quelle année je suis
monté à paris en
j'étais donc chez restaurant la mare et
on accélère un tout petit peu parce que
vous savez que tu as cucq des rayons
directs que la rencontre contre nous
elle regarde et on enlève les lardons et
ont été blanchis alors blanchir safer
non pas à nettoyer comme on le sait est
rousse et sans aucune astuce tout à
l'heure ça sert à enlever le de celle qu
un peu le gras également le gras reste
dans l'eau chaude
un grand moment nous sommes en direct
je prends cette casserole et je dégage
mettant nos voilà j'ai failli me brûler
une fois de plus très bien nause herbe
on met les herbes du jardin que vous
trouvez sur tous les marchés c'est la
pleine saison des terres bien là
pratiquement toute l'année maintenant on
ajoute les darons va justifier l'argent
un petit souvenir de cuisine la raison
est-ce que vous en avez beaucoup bavé
pour apprendre ce dur métier jouer mais
je suis sûr pour éviter des bons moments
passés quand il ya des très bons moments
et des fous du quart d'heure comme on
dit voilà alors là on crème au kram
combien de deux manières de servir et on
mélange très bien comme n'ai plus besoin
de la crème
s'en servir à tout à l'heure parfait
voilà attention
voilà ce que je peut nettoyer la peau
je suis un maniaque
oui j'allais les maîtres parfaire non un
meilleur ouvrier de france de cuisine
prend sa petite assiette c'est pas mon
copain jean nourrigat qui ferait ce
genre d'expérience je vais bientôt le
recevoir sur son plateau vous allez voir
c'est un grand chef mais des techniques
diffèrent totalement
enlevée alors qu'angers c'est pesé on en
a déjà planché la première fois que je
vois enlever la plante en direct on
essuie encore un peu gilles on se
dépêche on se dépêche que sinon on va à
regarder c'est très beau une neige c'est
pas la saison mais quand même hop
voilà
alors là on prend un bon morceau
copieusement comment est ce qu'on fait
la pâte feuilletée gilles vous souhaitez
moi j'ai une rue je vais voir mon
pâtissier ou mon boulanger lui dit
bonjour monsieur le pâtissier
pourriez-vous me vendre 500 g de pâte
feuilletée en général sa marque et vous
avez également le surgelé dans les
grandes surfaces voilà mes mais pour la
retraite on le fabriquait l'on prend 500
g de farine que l'on mélange avec 125
grammes d'eau willie roaf exion une
patte g 500 grammes on est allé comme je
fais là l'heure actuelle voilà et à
l'intérieur on met 500 g de beurre en
pommade prévient gilles ça suffit on
arrête le rouleau pour les scènes de
ménage vous le gardez précieusement
peu frais ça peut servir on utilise
maintenant
voilà alors vite un peu de beurre que
l'on mais je vous passe le beurre je
vous gêne dans les seconds sera là la
ligne la voie à la fourchette
habituellement au café de la paix ils
prennent leurs doigts ils ont les doigts
profs ils se sont frottés les doigts
avec une grosse voilà c'est très bien
plus de beurre la spécialité c'est très
bon jeu chef a dit que c'était très bon
alors le jeu consiste à mettre ça
s'appelle une abaisse une baisse c'est à
ça n'a rien à voir avec
le clergé ce que j'veux pas du tout le
même orthographe
c'est très technique
regardez un rouleau à pâtisserie qui
peut servir même dans les cas les plus
désespérés et hop la patte coupée
alors on garnit
voilà
on garnit très rapidement mon cher
gilles parce que je peux vous garantir
que l' on aura beaucoup de mal à manger
cette recette à la fin de l'émission
voilà hop ça me fait plaisir de faire
accélérer un chef et surtout le chef du
café de la paix qui n'est pas le
n'importe quel siège avait pas dire le
dernier des chefs non qu'est ce que vous
avez gagné comme conclure gilles on met
un petit coup part de suivi de ses coûts
par dessus voilà rapidement on se
dépêche on se dépêche on se dépêche
oui vous me répondez pas vous avez gagné
combien de concours est ce un seul site
dites-nous lequel pour l'améliorer de
france maison et vous n'avez pas fait le
vase de sèvres les choses comme ça je me
suis confiant
je me suis trompé de chef de chef on
remballe légèrement valable on y va vite
fait
j'ai fait un thé ça se voit non défaut
60 ans voilà
ici parce que vous allez voir suprême
astuces et déjà de la couture il ya une
petite cheminée naturelle qui va
permettre
à l'intérieur dudit pas de bêtises si
gilles vous m'arrêtez l'intérieur de
s'affirmer de faire évaporer
l'eau des pommes de terre je continue de
faire un peu de rangement
[Musique]
non j'ai enlevé le jaune d'oeuf pourrait
peut-être que je vous remets le jeune
david
leyraud rapide
je sais change tout
alors là non pas délicatement du gendre
et prochain sommet pour colorer
passe pas ça y est hop mais si le
picasso c'est lui-même qui a repeint les
fresques du café de la paix qui sont
classés monuments historiques il a eu
une dérogation spéciale des beaux-arts
et là nous avons préchauffez votre four
thermostat à 2 150 à 250 nous avons fait
un tout petit défaut voilà c'était pas
de décor on n'a pas le temps j'ai sur
les rapides rats ont fait quand même des
décors voyez les chefs qui sont des
champions ne résiste pas à la décoration
et la gère voilà voilà alors on a mis le
four à 250 m voilà gilles et on enfourne
au foot il allait voir miracle de la
télévision car nous avions tricher on
avait donc chauffer notre four à 250 et
là nous sortons le pâté de pommes de
terre qui a écrit combien de temps
gilles 50 minutes 50 minutes au bout de
cinq ans
tiendrait alors on accélère si vous
n'avez pas tous noté vous tapez notre
codes minitel 36 15 il croise aurait la
recette ce gilles johanet du café de la
paix là
on accélère le mouvement
on y va très vite vous n'êtes pas
dépasser je vous félicite d'être aussi
une petite sieste et voilà on met un peu
de crème aux mets de la crème en
intérêts voilà on n'aura malheureusement
pas le temps de goûter cette merveille
en direct mais tout de suite après avoir
rendu l'antenne et bien nous allons
faire un noeud ressort à cette
préparation que gilles vient de réaliser
en direct devant vous j merci infiniment
bravo parce que vraiment ça vous avez eu
chaud
[Musique]